[Musica]
oggi cominciamo da un albero un albero
di noce in particolare non c'è un albero
molto nobile molto prezioso dal noce si
ottengono frutti si ottiene un liquore
anche si ottiene anche un combustibile
dal dall'olio e naturalmente
dopo molti anni si può ottenere anche
del prezioso legname legame che ad
esempio storicamente nei secoli è stato
utilizzato nella città di venezia per
costruire le forcole le formule che sono
quegli oggetti che sostengono i reni
nelle gondolo e in alta in altre
imbarcazioni tradizionali e che sono
costruite da maestri come il mio amico
saverio che tramandano di generazione in
generazione delle delle pratiche delle
esperienze che vengono appunto da assai
lontano e stato proprio saverio a
raccontarmi una una storia interessante
una tradizione che ha a che fare proprio
con con in noce nelle nelle campagne
venete si usava piantare un noce quando
nasceva un bambino piccolo era una sorta
di immaginazione del futuro era se
vogliamo costruire in qualche maniera il
futuro ad e di questo bambino che
nasceva ma non solo suo anche anche
dell'ipo anche dei suoi figli perché
sono un dolce prima ad esempio diventare
utilizzabile per per falegnameria
richiede 60 70 anni e diciamo che questa
pratica di così insomma questo pensiero
quest'ispirazione di pensare al futuro
dei nostri figli è qualcosa che ci
accomuna
oggigiorno addirittura per taluni anche
in maniera drammatica no pensando a chi
per esempio è costretto arrivare il
dramma di di lasciare i propri figli in
mani di qualcun altro perché magari
attraverso in un mare per abbandonare
paesi in guerra o in povertà
eppure eppure accade anche che noi oggi
qui nei nostri nei nostri ricchi paesi
questi noci non li piantiamo più anzi in
gran parte li abbiamo tagliati negli
anni 60 70 c'è stato un uso
indiscriminato e siamo diciamo non
facciamo più
questa questa operazione questa
operazione di immaginare il futuro
è effettivamente un bel problema il
problema perché non solo non lo
immaginiamo ma in qualche maniera lo
subiamo peggio ancora lo facciamo subire
agli altri
ci sono molti esempi che si potrebbero
fare ma pensiamo ad esempio al tema
dell'ambiente entro pochi decenni si
dice che avremo più plastica che pesci
nel mare oppure pensiamo anche appunto
l'ambiente inteso come clima in cui
viviamo l'uso indiscriminato che stiamo
facendo dell'energia lo spreco di
risorse che la natura impiegato
veramente magari centinaia e migliaia
sono milioni di anni per realizzare bene
noi forse dovremmo cercare di essere più
attenti
anzi senza forse senz'altro e per fare
questo la ricerca scientifica ci può ci
può aiutare perché la ricerca
scientifica ha un po in comune con
l'idea di con la strada del noce no
perché tante volte si pianta un seme
senza ben sapere cosa succederà o
comunque sapendo che le le cose verranno
molti risultati verranno molto molti là
nel tempo il caso di heinrich hertz per
esempio il primo primo fisico che ha
rivelato le onde elettromagnetiche
previste qualche anno prima da maxwell
merz nel 1887 e lui non sapeva bene no a
cosa sarebbero servite lo disse anche ma
fanno a prova della teoria del maestro
maxwell ma 9 l'idea di quale saranno le
loro applicazioni
eppure oggi sappiamo che somma solo per
fare un paio di esempi fra tanti le onde
elettromagnetiche sono alla base della
della nostra di moltissimi aspetti della
nostra società che siamo alle
comunicazioni giusto per dirne una ma
anche giusto per fare un altro esempio
dalla cura la cura dei tumori per
esempio che si fa con microonde e quindi
diciamo la ricerca scientifica è proprio
in molti casi
un un immaginario il futuro piantando
piantando un semi di noce accade anche
oggi no i nostri e notizie proprio di
qualche giorno fa che sta per partire la
realizzazione di un nuovo grande
miglioramento dell'attuale
dell'acceleratore lhc che fra una decina
quindicina d'anni ci permetterà di
esplorare nuove frontiere della fisica
della materia e che delle interazioni
fondamentali chi lo costruisce oggi
forse magari neanche lo vedrà in
operazione o comunque non vedrà tutti i
risultati che potrà ottenere e allo
stesso modo anche noi anch'io stesso
diciamo in qualche maniera
nella mia attività di ricerca mi occupo
di qualcosa che che va forse oltre
addirittura la mia aspettativa di vita
la il tentativo di portare sulla terra
un pezzo di sole ovvero riprodurre in
laboratorio la fusione dell'idrogeno
problema diciamo che nasce da una
necessità impellente vi citavo prima il
discorso della questione energetica
immaginare un futuro significa anche
immaginare un futuro sostenibile dal
punto di vista energetico per i nostri
figli per le generazioni future quello
che stiamo avendo oggi certamente non lo
è la fusione può dare una risposta può
dare un contributo fondamentale da
questo punto di vista perché tanto
vediamo cos'è la fusione in sostanza è
un processo tutto sommato elementare
attraverso il quale due nuclei leggeri
due nuclei di isotopi dell'idrogeno si
fondono uno con l'altro e producono un
neutrone e dell'elio e in questo
riarrangiamento diciamo della struttura
nucleare della materia si libera si
libera energia energia che poi può
essere trasformata in energia elettrica
e da una serie di pregi notevoli intanto
è un processo intrinsecamente libero da
co2 non si usano combustibili fossili si
basa su un combustibile sostanzialmente
limitato acqua ad acquisire ottiene l
ulteriore litio ampiamente presente
nella crosta terrestre da cui si ottiene
poi il trizio è intrinseca
mentre sicura non ha questi diciamo
proprio che per natura non tanto per
scelta dell'uomo non da non dà luogo a
scorie radioattive di lunga durata
non diciamo non espone a rischi di
proliferazione degli armamenti quindi
diciamo senza dubbio è una fonte che ha
notevoli vantaggi oltre a quello di
darci la possibilità di costruire delle
diciamo insieme alle rinnovabili insieme
a l'immagazzinamento dell'energia delle
fonti
diciamo concentrate che consentono ad
esempio lo sviluppo di una economia dei
trasporti basata per esempio
sull'elettricità bene voi direte allo
rarefatta è in realtà in realtà non è
ancora fatta un po difficile una delle
difficoltà fondamentali e che questi due
nuclei che noi vogliamo far fondere in
realtà non amano molto fondersi tra loro
perché sono carichi positivamente quindi
tenderebbero a respingersi e noi per
cercare di vincere questa loro naturale
tendenza di riscaldiamo le riscaldiamo
molto a temperatura che sono addirittura
maggiori delle temperature al centro del
sole 100 milioni e più di gradi
centigradi a queste temperature
questi nuclei diciamo acquistano
velocità estremamente elevate si
scontrano uno con l'altro
e in questo scontro possono avvicinarsi
a distanze tali da poter far sì che la
repulsione elettrostatica venga invece
vinta dalla forza attrattiva
dall'interazione attrattiva nucleare
ecco questo è quello che noi che noi
cerchiamo di fare naturalmente il
problema e cercare di realizzare una
bottiglia una scatola che è che possa
contenere un pezzo di sole e anche
questa naturalmente è scientificamente
tecnologicamente non è per nulla banale
abbiamo imparato a farlo abbastanza bene
utilizzando dei campi magnetici sono in
sostanza delle delle ciambelle tori da
lì in cui disegniamo introduciamo dei
campi magnetici questi campi magnetici
sono in grado di tenere il nostro
combustibile lontano dalle pareti
materiali del contenitore e quindi
tenerlo insieme
in una porzione di spazio limitata dove
possiamo usarlo proprio per cercare di
ottenere l'energia l'energia che ci
serve bene questa questa storia nasce
nasce è una lunga coda lunga storia di
ricerca non è proprio direi a quasi
l'età di un noce di un noce adulto nasce
dopo la seconda guerra mondiale negli
anni nei primi anni 50 1 i protagonisti
e andrei sakharov forse qualcuno ricorda
vince vince il premio nobel per la pace
ed è stato anche un grandissimo fisico a
lui proprio a lui si deve insieme al suo
collega tam uno dei primi lavori che
identificano il top ma è una di queste
configurazioni che noi usiamo dall'epoca
si è fatta si è fatta molta strada
abbiamo fatto errori abbiamo fatto siamo
tornati indietro abbiamo avuto anche
tantissimi bei risultati
abbiamo fatto grandi spinte in avanti
ripensamenti su l'evoluzione classica
della scienza da da da quel seme cam
piantato i nostri diciamo i nostri
maestri decenni fa abbiamo fatto fatto
tanta strada anche canc qui in italia
per esempio questo che vedete è
l'esperimento rfx a padova dove ho
lavorato per molti anni e che uno degli
esperimenti protagonisti della della
storia ma anche oggi dell'attualità
nella ricerca sulla fusione è sempre qui
in italia tra tra poco anzi proprio in
queste settimane abbiamo cominciato la
progettazione di un nuovo grande
esperimento che verrà realizzato in
italia si direbbe completamente made in
italy si chiama dtt diverto testo kamke
e che in qualche maniera rappresenterà
per per noi e anche per le soprattutto
per le generazioni che verranno per i
miei studenti di oggi ma anche per gli
studenti dei miei studenti è un po il
futuro e che dovrà dare una importante
aiuto per quello che è un po il nostro
scopo fondamentale cioè quello di
realizzare infine un esperimento un
reattore che possa produrre
dall'idrogeno dalla fusione
dell'idrogeno elettricità un passo
fondamentale sarà quindi per iter che
questo esperimento che stiamo costruendo
nel sud della francia molto più grande e
anche di dtt a cui contribuiscono sette
grandi realtà come l'unione europea
negli stati uniti il giappone e la cina
l'india la corea alla russia e che
comincerà le sue attività fra circa una
decina d'anni e se avrà il compito
proprio di dimostrare che la fusione e
scientificamente fattibile sarà seguito
poi da un reattore sperimentale che si
chiamerà demo allora è chiaro che come
vi dicevo torniamo torniamo al nostro
albero è chiaro che questa è una ricerca
che si è sviluppata e si sviluppa lungo
lungo parecchi decenni quando avremo
energia elettrica una domanda che dalla
fusione che spesso mi viene rivolta e ce
l'avremo direi con ormai siamo
abbastanza consapevoli forse in passato
i maestri sono stati un po troppo
ottimisti oggi siamo un po più certi dei
tempi conosciamo le difficoltà e credo
che sia abbastanza tranquillo poter dire
che avremo energia elettrica da fusione
nella seconda metà di questo secolo
certo si potrebbe anche far prima esse
ci fosse veramente una volontà anche da
parte dei nostri amministratori di
investire di più ma ama ma tant'è
insomma il problema complesso e quindi
questo arriverà appunto fra
nella seconda metà del secolo è
senz'altro oltre la mia aspettativa di
lavoro e probabilmente anche a oltre la
mia aspettativa di vita quindi mi viene
naturale un po col passare degli anni
anche che inter mi disse se se ne vale
la pena
insomma perché mi accorgo che questa
cosa va un po oltre alla fine mi
risponde di sì certamente perché anche a
me insomma diciamo mi piace l'idea di
essere anch'io uno di queste persone che
hanno aiutato a piantare questo piccolo
seme che vi auguro un domani possa
diventare un grande noce e contribuire a
risolvere questa grande questione
energetica grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]